Speaker 1: There is new polling that reveals the
priorities of Republican voters in 2024, and it
is utterly and fundamentally cuckoo for Cocoa
Puffs. The modern American conservative movement
is focus on some really wild stuff. CBS News
poll on how 2024 Republican presidential primary
race could be Trump versus Trump fatigue. This is
this is super interesting. At this early stage of
the primary to the CBS News article reads, To the
extent the Republican primary is a contest at all
right now, it looks like it's one between Trump
and a sentiment one might call Trump fatigue.
And Trump is winning that matchup easily. Here's
why MAGA sounding ideas are widely held in the
Republican electorate, an environment that plays
heavily to Trump's advantage. There's big demand
for a candidate who says Trump won in 2020, who
challenges woke ideas, who doesn't criticize Trump
and for good measure, makes liberals angry.
Trump leads in all of those areas. Meanwhile,
there are some Republicans who say they're
exhausted by Trump and he's too controversial,
but they are greatly outnumbered today. Check
this out. Up top answers from likely Republican
primary voters. These are folks who, based on
their answers, have been categorized as likely
to vote in the primary primary. Remember, that's
a critically important detail. A 2024 Republican
nomination, likely Republican primary voters
prefer a candidate who 85% challenges woke ideas.
Hellboy, 66% opposes any gun restrictions.
61% say Trump won the 2020 election
and 57% makes liberals angry. Now, there are
two layers within which this is interesting.
The first layer is Republicans for so long
have been insisting we care about issues of
importance to all Americans economic issues, jobs,
inflation, something like that. We're supposed
to believe that's what they care about. When you
look at the polls, the likely Republican primary
voters care about very different things. The most
interesting part of this is that. These interests.
Are likely to lead to a Republican candidate that
is out of step with the country as a whole. Let
me explain what I mean by that. When Trump
was arrested and his approval went up among
Republican primary voters, one of the things we
saw, we surmised we noticed is that while it is
likely to help Trump in the primary by energizing
his base because he's been treated so unfairly,
you know, the whole thing, it's not likely to
get him any new votes in the general election.
And similarly, when we looked at Ron DeSantis
potentially running an Anti-woke campaign,
while that plays relatively well with Republican
primary voters, when you survey the country as
a whole, wokeness, for lack of a better term, is
actually the more popular position. And similarly,
when you look at some of these things, if 85% of
likely Republican primary voters want a candidate
that challenges woke ideas, but roughly 57 to
60% of the country sides with wokeness on trans
issues and on so many other issues, you have a
scenario in which the person that Republicans
are most likely to select to represent them in
November of 2024 is not actually the person most
likely to win that general election. Now, this
isn't news to us. When you look at polling that
does primary and then does hypothetical general
election matchup, you see Trump does really well
in the primary but loses to Biden, generally
speaking, on average loses to Biden in the
November election. So there's a few layers where
this is interesting. One, it confirms that the not
just Republicans in general, because you could be
a Republican who plans to vote in November of 24,
but you're not engaged enough to vote in the
primary. So this really is likely primary voters,
the likely primary electorate of the Republican
Party, is very much out of step with the way
that the country as a whole is going.
That's number one. And then number two,
we've said for a while now, Republican elected
officials, Republican candidates better said,
have abandoned policy in part because they're
losing the country on policy. So instead they
talk about this sort of stuff, let's do nothing on
guns. Let's fight wokeness, let's ban books, let's
stop drag shows, whatever else the case may be.
That is in itself also not apparently a winning
ideology or a winning platform. They've lost on
policy, so they've abandoned that and they've
moved on to cultural issues, but they're also
not winning the cultural issues Now nationally
and yesterday we looked at how they're losing on
abortion in other areas. So what are they to do?
The answer is obvious. It's what they've been
doing. You try to win elections by saying you won
even if you lost. And that should really scare all
of us because it means they will almost certainly
try it again in 2024. Lest anyone forget, or maybe
you misplaced our pamphlet on membership. I do
want to remind you that our program is primarily
funded by our viewers, by our listeners through
something called the membership program. You can
sign up at join Packman dot com. We do an extra
show every single weekday for our members. We also
offer commercial free audio and video feeds of the
show for you. We make the show available hours
earlier every day to our members and you can
get a discount. I mean, listen, the prices are so
reasonable. But if you'd like a 50% discount, you
can use the coupon code indicted to save off of
the cost of a membership at join Packman dot com